if you overuse twitter does it mean your
life's in the
uh
why not
yeah they send tons of angry tweets to
make their miserable lives complete
just 25 of americans use twitter and
just 25 percent of those who use it are
responsible for 97 of the posts
according to a new study from the pew
research center
so funny 25 is a pretty small group and
it's likely much smaller when you remove
people like me who only tweet to promote
stuff and don't forget i'll be in newark
new jersey on december 12th get your
tickets at g gutfelt.com and also by
andrew yang's book it's called forward
now it's probably it's probably more
like 10 percent that's doing all the
idiotic tweeting that the media keeps
pretending reflects actual public
opinion so maybe it might not be such a
good idea that we keep using it as a
barometer for who needs to be canceled
fired and banished from public life why
not do it the old-fashioned way by
seeing if accused witches can float
trolls shouldn't have more power in real
life than they do in a game of dungeons
and dragons the study also found that
people who are the most active on
twitter are also more than twice as
likely to experience abuse on the
platform which means they look for
trouble the way hunter biden looks for
chunks of parmesan cheese
honestly we've already solved this
problem years ago
are you worried that your social network
is mining your personal information and
sharing it with political operatives i
can't believe facebook using my
information to elect donald trump how
could they do this it never ends with
this [ __ ] guy
maybe you should try not connected never
heard of it it's the world's first
offline online social network huh
it's on your computer right now if you
want to give it a try
[Music]
hey how did you get it on my computer
let's not worry about that now just give
it a try okay i think i'll post a clever
tweet about the president see what
happens
the key to not connected's highly
advanced technology is that it looks
just like most social networks but
you're not on the internet in fact
you're not connected to anything your
posts simply bypass twitter and facebook
and end up here
meanwhile what do you see wow
it was retweeted one thousand times
every one of my tweets is retweeted one
thousand
times thanks not connected
you know mercedes it's
how scary is it to think that like we
believe we believe that maybe it could
just be a hundred thousand people that
are actually tweeting i mean it's and
and yet we give we we amplify the
importance of this network and it
actually does influence people's lives
well you know as a mother of five
younger kids and talking to like the
teenage kids and the college kids are
like we don't even use twitter they're
like on instagram they're on different
social media platforms so and tick tock
so it makes it into this they're not
even paying attention they think the
adults are just insane for going on
twitter and acting like a bunch of
school kids like in in bullying each
other to school yard now with that being
said said matt schlapp spends a lot of
time on twitter and let me tell you he
gets into trouble all the time that's
your husband yeah it's always they'd say
it's like it is mostly dudes yes right
which is it which is interesting what's
weird about it is it's it's funny like i
get no like i will try to promote a book
or promote a show yeah it makes no
difference in fact if i if i don't tweet
about this show
uh or i tweet about it you don't see the
ratings change at all it stays the same
yeah so so but however twitter can
actually impact your life yeah you can't
do it you can't do the reverse twitter
is a fight club for people who don't
want to get hit
that's what it is you go on there and
get cold names to get beat up and stuff
like that it is it's incentivized
conflict because it rewards the most
extreme takes on the ideological
opposite that people will give you like
digital dopamine and your phone you get
a bunch of likes but you're really just
road raging with someone who's not on
the same highway
it's so stupid like when you really
think about it but the dangerous part is
that they do have say like you know what
i mean they're driving news narratives
part of the reason we're watching a kyle
rittenhouse trial right now is because
people on twitter had more empathy for a
dirt bag who sexually assaulted a woman
at knifepoint and got shot by the cops
then the actual woman who got sexually
assaulted and the kid who got
potentially abducted and in their world
view that made sense so the whole
country is on fire right now because
they have a say that they don't deserve
these people we know who they are
they're losers you know and there's
nowhere in the world where there'd be a
guy would be better off if only he spent
another five minutes on twitter no one
is writing that country song you're not
going to be on your deathbed going i
wish i had another hot take on chad if
only i had one more i'll be live
tweeting the whole thing
do you know you've got you don't do as
much social networking i do i post but
then i just don't look at it like i
don't look at what people reply because
i can logically understand these people
like they're losers who would you know
go after a stranger like this who would
say that i can logically understand that
but still when i see it i'm like oh my
god why would i say that
and i like i get upset or in the case of
my instagram comments disgusted like
does your wife know you're on here doing
this
i just don't look i can still post but i
just don't look yeah that just takes
that's because of my impeccable
self-control that is amazing there are
nice there are people on twitter who
follow who watch the show and tweet i
actually enjoy that yeah more than i
watch because i've already watching the
show right now so i look at what
twitter's doing so i know everybody
who's watching right now andrew you we
talked earlier about the great cool off
can you actually have a cool off
with with it with a with a social media
platform that thrives on not cooling off
uh it's tough you know what's fun is i
think you and i got in touch on twitter
that yeah the platform does have a lot
of utility and it drives a lot of press
narratives to your point uh jonathan
height who's a scholar at nyu talks
about a setting where you could actually
not see the stuff that's uh consistently
more aggressive inflammatory derogatory
imagine that imagine if you could set
that kind of filter that's the kind of
thing we're going to need because right
now again the extremity gets rewarded
the more aggressive i am on twitter the
more likely i am to get engagement get a
rise out of someone right action when i
get on twitter and i'm on twitter an
awful lot because of my job
uh you do have to kind of put the hard
hat on and go in and just and if you see
something just let it slide right off
your back because if you engage with it
you're just gonna end up heightening the
visibility and rewarding the person
who's like ooh let me see if i can stick
it to something yeah god love the mute
button is what you're saying the mute
button is the greatest thing about
twitter because people keep yelling at
you
but now i block yeah
[Laughter]
but you're right like there's so many
it's so funny there's so many broken
people like i can post a picture it'd be
like it's my dog's birthday and they'll
be like yeah but
[Laughter]
my trump didn't vote you know what i
mean in fact or did he well he's dead
he's a democrat i voted in georgia
all right i don't even know what that
means
i'll show you so if you do this buy this
book that will have an impact if you say
buy this book on twitter not so much
yeah he's a he's impressed no i know i
believe it
he's gonna shoot up the charts you're
gonna sell at least a hundred thousand
tonight